basically he was working as a consultant
to the Dallas Cowboys
uh but trying to train their
quarterbacks how to
play that game fast claims it was
teachable that you could maybe as a
quarterback has to take in the whole big
picture open Focus mode and see the
whole picture lock in on the receiver
and then only see the receiver and
exclude everything else so in that case
just in a matter of seconds hopefully
fractions of a second even switch modes
from open parallel massively parallel to
tightly focused
unobjective mode right really that's
where I see consciousness
existing it's like
what it feels like to be in
superposition
uncollapsed way for what you've decided
something then it's
Consciousness in the system to me as a
controls Engineers where we handle the
undecidable
and so that's why I'm on the same way
we've learned as Roger Penrose when they
say it's got to be a cut
a Quantum process involved in all of
this when it comes to Consciousness and
and I basically and you know and
within the spectrum of Consciousness I
see
masculine Consciousness being a serially
dominated mix of the twos parallels
it's more deterministic but it's still
got to have
that tension was
the background and
permanent is more
holistically oriented but it's still got
to have that objective scenario that's
provided by the masculine side so just
saying we're playing with a spectrum
of Consciousness across the space that's
one side closer to the parallel
Earth specs of it and one side closer to
the
linear
serial aspects of it all
so Jeff welcome to simulation
looks good to have you on
also really good to get connected by Ori
for that episode yeah
looking forward to
playing together especially on the
conversation of paradox
which is so fundamental to the nature of
what this is
so
let's
there's there's sort of uh two ways we
can take this we can take this and
giving a bunch of context
about uh you and how you came to where
you are today which I think is helpful
and then we can also jump straight in to
Paradox you can also weave if you'd like
yeah the two
so why don't I'll pass it over to you
and you can take
take over and then I'll interject as we
as we go through
yes um
some go with the flow I do works pretty
good I think but
one problem I'm facing here
paradoxically is that
the language part of my brain is the
opposite side from where I mostly live
anyway because I look at it as
uh anyway our
I kind of feel like we are occupying a
an Adaptive
general purpose controller
which is our Neurology of our evolved
Neurology of our brain
and for some weird reason it had to be
split in half with specialized
hemispheres
and if you get into it very far there's
a cleft in the
run front to back it also
compartmentalizes those hemispheres
more and so
so what I my point of view from personal
experience and interpretation of that
experience
is that I'm running on a four-cylinder
Paradox engine okay
uh currently previously I was probably
running on a two-cylinder paradox engine
um
and
the cylinders of that I would kind of
throw into a Briggs Myers context of
thinking and tuition sensing feeling
it's like there's specialized sub-brains
that we're working from that
help us navigate and survive in the
world from
I mean somehow through evolutionary
biology
we've
our system has evolved to survive in the
world and there's these different modes
of survival that are
or
currently have been discovered by
evolution
and is reflected in their interpretation
personality theory of what's really
pretty complex mess
in their heads that
you know to say that it's clean cut this
way is asking too much it's it's
um
one way
I mean for me I started out you know in
hindsight being mostly running on
an introverted which in prefrontal
cortex system for as I know
thinking intuition most dominant
intuition probably
system so
and dominant intuition is kind of on the
opposite side of the hardware that's
processing body science and
and some of the language stuff from my
understanding of generalizations of
cognitive neurotypical cognitive
architecture
so
that's where I'm coming from just based
on my being a controls engineer about
training
and and trying to understand how
how a soft tuning control system can
be set up and
and how we can be evolved into that and
plus I played around with some tricks to
move between dominance patterns
uh when I was around Thursday I played
around with some Kundalini breathing
tricks that would shift hemispherical
Dome and then so they found that I could
in it it sounded bogus to me because I'm
not into that at all but
I found like hell I could switch between
uh more of the
dominant which was probably my normal
pattern to more of a left dominant by
using their tricks and tried it out
climbing the local mountain Pig for my
31st birthday that I'd never dared to do
it before and
and they finally figured out the reason
I couldn't stand it was because my
visual system was throwing these images
of me falling as I tried to go up
precarious trails and and
you know watching other people even at
Heights I would see them soon just
interpret that as an evolved survival
thing more of a maternal trait and
then anything probably and then
was using the breathing techniques I
played around with the switch to
wherever left hemisphere dominance I'll
add just one away and all I was I was
just right there where's the next hand
hold where's the next foothold
going up without any of that flashing
into my Consciousness and
right the idea that I could move my
Consciousness around in the hardware
right I'm probably manipulating blood
flow or attention yes yes
was
anyway it was
it maybe have a different point of view
of what I was and what defined me
because it's right like I was just one
thing based on the my natural
can't just stick but
there's all sorts of possibilities
depending on where I was at in my head
at the time basically
right
so
and
which makes sense and just want to hit
the ball back and say it makes perfect
sense also because
the modulatory nature
is also based in electromagnetic
Principle as well
so
it makes sense that
neurologically speaking we could be
talking about oxygen or
um or or glucose or blood we could be
talking about these types of things
and
even more fundamentally even more
layer zero let's say is energy or
electromagnetism and feeling neural
neurologically speaking the feeling
one's ability to shift between something
that's tremendously logical or ordered
patterned and something that is
absolutely not that whatsoever and is
has in no form at all has no logic is
totally uh intuitive could be Primal
um there's many
um and there's many ways that those two
things interplay and to get really good
at all of that and modulating between
that can you you know modulating into a
sense of self
and other
and then modulating out
of a sense of self and other into one
consciousness
so yeah there's a this is this is really
fundamental it's crucial yes
I I found I played around with that like
I took a
a
standardized job service type dexterity
test during this time I was playing
around with that when I was 30.
surgery people on the roughly in and
when I was at 15 I'd had to take the
exact same test moving washers on pegs
and I got sixth percentile when I was
15. totally introverted totally not
connected to my body
but then at that when I was doing this
over again I was playing around with
this and they
I decided I was going to become my hands
for this test
and so I just put all of my attention
into them into my hands
while I performed the test and I came in
with like 96 percentile on dexterity
at that point just by becoming my hands
for the dexterity test right really
convinced me that we can
change
what's considered to be fixed traits or
not so fixed
it's very Dynamic actually
uh
the thing I also found that I could put
my attention by playing around with the
Left Right dominance I could put myself
in the middle just by intentionality
with my intention system and then just
intuitively I felt like somewhere in the
center should be the best play I mean I
felt
felt like it was a good place to be it
was just sort of centered between those
two possibilities exactly that was the
most spacious exactly
and so I played around with it I took it
off early sort of
didn't follow through Forever on the
other they sort of worked towards it but
uh
about 20 years later I was ex trying to
understand
some developmental things that come
about in people and get locked in an
early childhood things to do with
attachment system and
as shame and
uh probably insecure attachment style
and the frame of John Bowlby uh anyway
so I said well shame's just a word I
want to go into shame I want to feel
viscerally what is this thing that
people are talking about which is
it feels like suicide
to actually anyway
please continue uh going there if you
wish
all I know is
I learned to be careful what you asked
for
yep
anyway
uh
a couple days after I did that in a safe
container was an online group that I was
involved in at the time
that was listening to the universe in a
single at them
on the audiobook called it was working
which Universe in the single atom seems
like pretty good play on Paradox
actually
yeah to the book by the Dalai Lama
uh I just had this sudden bang one cycle
I mean from a
control from my engineering training I
would say it was a instantaneous shift
to a different stable harmonic right
system however the over Consciousness
fits together with the body which I
don't claim to
have that figured out to lead to the
bottom but
it but it happened I mean so now I've
got this thing that I don't believe in
I've got to deal with because
heart of it felt like a connecting
which across the brain as a connecting
but it felt like a non-local connecting
like yeah reconnecting with source is
something just this light Cloud kind of
yes yes
it also felt like it was
completing the
a conceptual structure that
that all of a sudden there's been this
discomfort or this disease that
had been living with and all of a sudden
that was gone it's like also nice the
socially
conveyed model they had of the world and
how things worked
got reassembled into something that made
sense to me finally and there was any
conceptual distress anymore right
which
had come in the process of listening to
the Dalai Lama's stuff mostly
but
right anyway and so that beautiful made
me feel like I was suddenly manic it was
pretty intense
and it took me a few months to sort I
miss too much of it was really intense
like emotionally like I went from
thinking
an intuitive dominant into a more
extroverted of a suddenly extroverted on
the Briggs Myers test if I did one or
before I'd been introverted
and I was really body sense of aware and
emotionally above the charts from my
history
and so
over a period of a couple of months I
figured out how to time that and control
it and surf at sort of and yes yes since
that time I sort of weave in and out of
that introverted extroverted space
depending on what's going on in my life
today right
but you got to be really interested in
what is consciousness what how does this
fit together it's like
yeah what's going on here right that's
the thread to pull and and it also was
you know there was a materialist
explanation of hemispheres connecting
but it was also
this thing that people talk about in
religion and spirituality of
of reconnecting with source which
so
I could have my materials explanation
which for me is probably more
comfortable
but it also had the other property too
which is
one thing that got me kind of paying
attention to Paradox early on in that
going into that mode
if that makes sense yes
I would like to ask
about
if you feel like
the nature of Shame
is very
directly at the root
intertwined with the nature of self
yeah I actually went through a journey
I've got a whole I've probably got two
feet of shelf of books on shame
uh the immediate
the feeling was in that experience with
Sheamus root of all suffering and evil
in the world but
right uh there's
actually a centeredness between there
and
I mean
so uh it
after a journey through understanding
how she
shame is
so so part of those experiences and I
found out from talking to other people
is a really narcissistic
surge
of fear anyway
I won from stink of narcissism that
comes with those experience those shifts
like that
and and so there's a so there's a part
of shame that
Keeps Us grounded that we're imperfect
Works in progress yeah yeah that's
actually beneficial in grounding and
helpful
and there's the show there's another
kind of Shame that's
I mean from an evolutionary point of
view
this is an inhibitory Drive
that makes us conform
to the social environment we're born
into
yes and there's inherent cultural flaws
in every system
that are a problem
and the obvious one is pretty
common all over between all religions is
just this
male dominance of just narrative
to excuse Society to a certain masculine
bias that's really not telling us any
favors at this point
and the source of a lot of our cultural
problems but
um
anyway there's
so I have a from a System Dynamics point
of view from my training
if you look at the evolution of life on
the planet there's
a lot of evolution of survival of the
fittest evolution by selection
which is a slow adaptation that
requires most of the way to Extinction
events
to realign and discover how to survive
in a given local environment
and it it has a tendency to just go
extinct
and so and that's where you find a lot
of insects microbes
but as and even
the the
lizard brain stuff you know it got to an
unstable point in dinosaurs that they
just wouldn't expect
and the mammals that replaced um are a
lot better at
adapting in one so there's
genetics has evolved so we can survive
in a variety of
environments that we adapt to in our
early childhood
to discover those
and
if you go down the mammalian leaving
reptilian cycle that plays out there too
so so there's adaptation in the life
cycle of the individual in the early
embryo you know early phases of that
development adapt to the local
environment and then they're kind of
locked in which
is a problem with some of the
personality what gets classified as
personality disorders but are actually
good adaptation into a bad environment
okay you're born into a dangerous
environment you're not supposed to feel
safe in that environment unfortunately
it's really not a happy life but it is a
survival life
I like to use cats for proxy
rather than talk about people so much
because it's more politically correct to
talk about feral cats
and how they're adapted to survive and
be
afraid of I mean they're always on edge
you're always looking for danger right
or you've got the cat that was born in
the house it's always safe everything's
wonderful there's no danger they're just
all prayers and fun
and
and there's that possibility for
adaptation is in the genetics of
cats obviously and my more good humans
Muslim most mammals have that adaptation
possibly built into them
and so rather than saying there's
personality disorders in humans
there's actually just normal
adaptation to the environment they were
born into right and and then beyond that
we have our language and
and memes and mimetics is there a way to
adapt within a mature life cycle it's
you know
our conditioning was tied in pretty
tightly in early childhood but we can
still adapt to new environments through
through learning and cultural
transmission
with language and whatever other systems
we have for
higher functions
so I see that there's these different
there's just been this evolution of
adaptability
that's been playing out and
there's not enough respect for it in the
society
and it's all just to work in progress
and
it's not doing us any good to demonize
other social orders that we don't
understand that's
more matter of being able to take
different points of view based on where
people are coming from and being able to
sort it out in a constructive healthy
manner
which requires being able to sit in the
middle between the two opposing points
of view I mean all you have to do is
look at the U.S Congress to figure out
exactly the system's broken and
taking people down the lizard brain
keeps it that way yes
we need higher cognitive functions to
actually sort out the problems right
we've created for ourselves
yes
be able to adapt to a really rapidly
changing the environment
right that makes sense of course
it's great hearing you weave the The
cosmological
evolutionary and biological
into the neurological and spiritual and
deconstructive uh conditioning side of
things and really resonant
um
and
um
yes very simply put
um
all
always has been and always will be that
Source light Cloud that's you
describe and
that's part of the game of the the
Paradox that well how can it be that and
how can I still feel
a sense of self and and separation and
location why do I still feel location
uh a sense of identity that's separate
from that source and whatnot
and so there's that conversation that we
can go uh and play on and then there's
another conversation that I feel like we
can play on which is the formation and
this might actually be more
it might be better to start here and
then we'll get there
which is what else is really at the root
along with shame
for what does shame let's say
evolve into that is more easily
um
acknowledgeable let's say to start
pulling on the thread into one's
subconscious yeah yeah I didn't really
get to the point on that very well
um so so
from a Dynamics point of view I
the neocortex I think I feel like we're
so adaptive adaptable at this point that
the system is inherently unstable
and that we need intergenerational
transfer
to of culture to keep the system stable
uh
and that shame is what enforces that
and it's a survival thing and it's
important
it has its place in the system
for intergenerational transfer of
content that we need to learn okay so it
has its place
um I have a a picture that I drew for a
presentation one time that looks like a
mushroom cloud
and if you an atomic explosion goes off
there's about there's just re-creation
and then there's a column that raises
vertically cylindrically
and that's how I see the individuation
path going as constrained by the
cultural environment
and it
it's important because without that
I would say
people becomes
so I will get there's a percentage of
the population where that's the case and
those are the people we classify as
Psychopaths or sociopaths
because they don't have that inhibition
it doesn't
give them the ability to resonate with
others empathically
and they just it's just a game it's all
just a game there's no they don't feel
that it feels like you're gonna die if
you don't conform here they can do
whatever they want
and they and they've rise to the top of
our culture because they they can play
the current culture is pretty much
focused on and ran type survival of the
fittest is Glory
right point of view right and they can
do it shamelessly they can do it without
worrying about hurting other people
um
right
I feel like what I experienced is that
shame system a change in topology took
the shame part offline by going into it
and dying into the
being totally transparent nothing to
worry about that way anymore
caused that system to shut down and
caused
all four cylinders to integrate
correctly without this hierarchical
enforcement of Conformity playing
anymore
and so
then that's the top of the mushroom
cloud basically this it's a very
creative space
it's what we need for solving problems
it's what we need for
be able to hold different points of view
in place without
having to choose between them
say that
say that again
which part so that's so that the the
sudden onset that I experienced I mean
there's different versions of this it
can be slow or sudden but the sudden
version
I feel like it it was that system
dropping out I mean I yeah
right dropped out and there was just a
sudden shift to another topology of
Consciousness that was integrating the
fourth of the four
more horizontal aspects of interpreting
reality and surviving in the world
in that
that Paradox engine point of view so I
was running on all four cylinders and
and that inhibitory
foreign there's a
sounding far-fetched point of view that
that some people have come across point
two and that's the idea of a toroidal
universe and I would say maybe a
toroidal Consciousness that
can only be integrating
so much at once
and that if it's integrating
hierarchically so that we're conforming
autonomic nervous system inhibitory
stuff that's associated with shame
that it can only pull in part of the
this horizontal plane that I'm just
that's the four cylinders
and so it's like I just flipped an axis
in the shame went away and uh right all
four were integrating now that's why I
suddenly experiencing my body sense and
my emotions so tightly because those
have been
but youngins would put in Shadow
exactly yeah I'm not in the shadow and
it's just instantly flipped into axis
and the other stuff shut down so now I'm
a functional psychopath
because I don't feel shame anymore
it's like the mushroom cloud
going horizontal now because I've
reached a certain level in the
confinement I don't know don't I'm
pretty good on fluid mechanics but I
still don't claim to understand the
mushroom Club all the way to the bottom
but it happens you know it
was just confining column that goes that
rises it's got the energy to rise of the
confined
call them up to a point and then it just
sort of spreads out and right and this
is this inhibitory shame it's a
confining space to socialize us up to a
point whereas we're socialized properly
to conform
in the environment we're in then we're
Cut Loose to
do our thing creatively and explore
possibilities and and help Society find
a better way maybe
interesting anyway
that's a work in progress but it's my
interpretation of what makes sense to me
the best in this system
I really enjoy that
and it feels good
now
um
there are a couple things here
um
one of them is I would like to
do a definition
of Shame and it looks like the first one
when you search for it online is very
powerful
um
a painful feeling of humiliation or
distress caused by the consciousness of
wrong or foolish Behavior
so
would you first would you have a
favorite one yes please it's about the
medical
uh so there's a book that was a joint
project between Carl Rogers
and Barry Stevens
she got
the feminine berries
Mishu wrote alternating sections with
Carl Rogers to try and explain his point
of view in a more feminine
interpretation
which
was a really good book
and then there she has a definition
it's
shame is
the difference
between
how I perceive my self to be
and how I perceive Society expects me to
be
very concise
yeah
pretty much knows it on the hill to me
it's just it's a perception of it's it's
like what it feels like to not conform
to the expectations that we
feel like Society expresses from expects
from us
and it's totally subjective it's totally
from our point of view it's not like
it's necessarily actually what Society
expects from us but it's how we perceive
a houseman right
how it's been transferred to us as an
expectation from those around us and
mostly unspoken
a lot of us body language right
it's not like just rules written down in
a book somewhere
your Society doesn't even follow those
it's interesting because the way that
you just described it is very powerful
and I love that and then the first
definition that seemed to pull up
um seem to have a a deep resonance with
the word repentance
so
I mean that's one thing the Catholic
Church gets right in my opinion is
they're confessional yes yes they get
that right right
because
we could say that the core thing that
we're uh talking about which is let's
say Union with this
Source like cloud
is accessed through this style of
inner work
so
repentance or in this definition
the going inward into the most painful
emotions that one carries perhaps like
rocks within oneself
are
some of the greatest ways especially
when some of those rocks have to do with
our own uh immoral Behavior
that's one of the best ways to uh
transmute those rocks into the very air
that they are made of
and
then feel expansion and feel healing and
feel space and love
and that seems to be the whole game
that's being played so
that
is a very powerful root
and then I like what you said too
because
if I'm creating
any sense
of separation
I'm
automatically interested in how I'm
being seen or perceived
because I'm localizing myself
I'm creating an illusion of a separate
other
and then I'm concerned about the way
that they're perceiving me
right
and then that whole
that is at the root that explodes into
so many other perceptions of
shame and lack and
um
all different kinds of of uh concerns
and worries and anxieties and
depressions and all this type of stuff
yeah that's powerful
here's another aspect to this that I
could was especially obvious to me when
they had that sudden shift and now
there's
uh we we all need
I mean because of the instability and
the individual and that
we need feedback we need validation
I mean there's controls I need to
obviously like feedback feed forward and
feedback opposites that play against
each other in this Paradox Space and
feed forward is the genetics a lot of it
and feedback is how we
how we learn from our mistakes and and
adapt uh
but
we talk about
a lot of those early problems that have
to do with shame come from
invalidation is a is a very literal form
of trauma right it doesn't show bruises
but right it just invalidating your
worth as a person uh your
Basic Instincts to behave a certain way
there's there's all sorts of ways that
we can be invalidated that cause a kind
of trauma and that's
what the I mean
aside from physical trauma
being obvious and causing problems
there's
just a I don't think anybody escapes
that kind of invalidation trauma yes
even in the best of circumstances
right
yeah and then that's so good
one of my one of my close friends uh
Sonia recently said
what would it look like this is with uh
like teaching how to interact with let's
say a close family something like what
would it look like if
uh if you weren't constantly in an
argument with who I am
yeah
so there's there's always some sort of a
so much invalidation trauma happening in
that in that regard like not basically
not allowing
uh to be
what is
the the natural natural of what is yeah
not allowing that
being in an argument with it yeah
and
Eckhart totally gets into stuff like
that I think in his books and stuff and
I've come across quite a few people
who've
got benefit from
his version of the
yeah I could probably recommend him even
though I haven't personally got into it
that deep
he has this model of a pain body and
and they're like I know quite a few
people who've been
helped by his books as far as an
external reference right
so there's an aspect of paradox and you
touched on it and the individual versus
Collective
Unity versus individual separation
it's one that murky brought to my
attention
in a book from us EKG guy called the
focal non-focal
attention system well he doesn't he
calls it open Focus
versus vocal the only one
so which is part of how it would there's
where we put our attention which was
really focusable attention versus the
background
yes that occurs and
yes
so that's
one place I really got into paradox
right that's a very powerful entry point
it's
it it's also the perfect one for
the localized non-localized which is
such a that's such a perfect one for
waking up it's such a good one yeah I I
have a map that I've created around the
Taoist point of view that basically it's
it's
serial versus parallel
modes and and the space in between that
and basically it's the space where I
feel Consciousness exists in different
degrees
parallel dominant versus serial dominant
and a space in between
explain parallel
versus serial dominant
explain the map
well I mean part of
what I've done the whole presentation on
was parallel learning
uh
a good I mean there's something in early
childhood called parallel play where
basically
kids watch other people play and do the
same other kids play and they imitate
it's it's aligned with imprinting and
more of an animal domain but
a good example of it would be my oldest
son
when he was through to
he was he like most puzzles and he would
just play the whole book of Maryse
supposedly he would just look at a moose
and draw the answer
there was no trial and error he just his
visual cortex was solving yeah without
any thought processes
to just presented its Gasol it's
a lot of people would call intuition
but it's really a parallel processing
thing that presents the results all at
once there's no paper trail on it we get
into that and in AI systems right and
it's also
I mean it's just how the visual cortex
works so everything's massively parallel
um the same sun when you got to algebra
had problems because
they could present a problem to him and
he could write the answer but he
couldn't show any steps in between
he had to learn how to go through the
steps because they marked it wrong when
they just presented the answer just tell
but
of course algebra is all about proofs
it's got to be logical linear
but is that cereal
that's that's per well all the steps in
between Are cereal yeah
uh
there's also an equivalence between
Syria or between parallel and rotation I
mean I got into that in mind ventilation
as a undergrad working with one
Professor I worked for when we prove
something anyway there was a well you
could actually
remap mind ventilation systems
by using rotational elements together
with translational elements and it's all
separated kind of neatly
it's kind of weird anyway
it's a mechanical engineering there's
lots of
translation versus rotation stuff to
deal with
led me to the idea that there's a basic
Paradox in the universe from the get-go
of
rotation versus translation
and then Consciousness as well let's
call it masculine feminine you can call
it
is it
parallel or
versus serial
I mean we talk about
I mean the Buddhists are into the
causality big time
which is linear causal stuff but there's
another kind of causality that's
parallel like just because you see a
whole bunch of turtles popping out of
the ground on the beach some place
doesn't mean it's not linearly causal
but massively parallel type all the eggs
that were laid at once are hatching at
once
so just fast there's it's a different
kind of causality
and and we're getting lots of com
touring machines are
are based on linear processes
but the graphic stuff they're coming out
with is massively parallel and
prevent present something that's
complementary
I mean there's a different words that
fit together with Paradox
complementarity is one of them
you know it takes both sides to make a
hole
in the complementary way just wave
particle duality
the idea that you can have something
that depends how you look at it as
comes through as a particle versus it
comes through as a wave and
it can be both depending on your point
of view that's a paradox isn't that
right it gets described as
complementarity
right
and so it's probably a local versus folk
or a focal versus non-focal kind of
paradox right right
so
one of the ways to look at this
then for those
um listening on audio
I would recommend also checking out the
video
version where this is embedded
so
is that the
the complement uh the complementality
supplementarity
complementarity yes complementarity
um
um the
uh the simultaneity the
um
the both
and
neither
the
all of that
um
is
is the middle or is the whole thing and
then
one of the best ways to describe the
Indescribable is through this
paradoxical viewing
of it
so Paradox and then Fable are probably
tightly related
yes
yes
right
there's another word that comes up
and there's another
aspect to this has to do with godel's
incompleteness theorem which is
decidability and and the point there's a
boundary between the computable and
what and the rest of the universe
whenever we try and objectify everything
there's a limit
that what can be objectified and then
and what can be computed
by a turing machine and there's a
there's a territory to explore in that
direction
probably falls under the word oracles
continue
uh and
and really that's where I see
consciousness
existing it's like
what it feels like to be in a
superposition
uncollapsed woe form what you've decided
something that is
consciousness in the system to me is a
controls Engineers where we handle the
undecidable
and so that's why I'm on
the same wavelength as Roger Penrose
when they say it's got to be a cup
a Quantum process involved in all of
this when it comes to Consciousness and
and I basically and you know and
within the spectrum of Consciousness I
see masculine Consciousness being a
serially dominated mix of the twos
parallels
it's more deterministic but it's still
got to have
that tension with
the background and
feminine is more
holistically oriented but it's still got
to have that objective Center that's
provided by the masculine side so just
saying we're playing with a spectrum
of Consciousness across the space that's
one side closer to the parallel
aspects of it and one side closer to the
linear
serial aspects of it all
right
right and the nice thing about
being very malleable
in one's modulatory ability
is to not box oneself into category
and therefore to be boxless
and
to be able to navigate into what can be
more parallel or more serial
and call upon frequencies of those
domains as
isn't flow
the one book I've built into by Lewis
family on the open Focus brand was
basically he was working as a consultant
to the Dallas Cowboys
uh but trying to train their
quarterbacks how to
play that game fast claims it was
teachable that you could maybe as a
quarterback has to take in the whole big
picture open Focus mode and see the
whole picture lock in on the receiver
and then only see the receiver and
exclude everything else so in that case
just in a matter of seconds hopefully
fractions of a second even switch modes
from open parallel massively parallel to
tightly focused
unobjective mode right okay that's great
that you bring a sport
it's one of the best
analogies it feels like and so relatable
to so many
uh
it is really the simultaneity of taking
in the whole
while also being able to vocalize on the
specific thing that needs to happen at
that time and it's really really
beautiful it's like also it's very
relatable even if one didn't necessarily
go really hard in playing sports in
one's life
so many people are fans of sport
so therefore when you're a fan of sport
you can also see this happening where
you're taking in the whole of the field
or the court or both teams and Etc
and then at the same time the field and
then at the same time you're honed in on
where is the ball right now
who is around the ball where's the ball
moving
and uh that's one of the best
yeah it's a really good analogy yeah
well one of the things that he brings up
in that book is he he says from an
evolutionary point of view it's the
Lioness on the heart
uh taking a herd of gazelles or whatever
and then having to lock in on one
specific Target and take it down and and
being able to being able to focus on one
is important for survival
but also it's tied in with the
sympathetic nervous system
uh for the attack mode
and so by being in focal mode a lot
we're also in sympathetic activation if
I mean
I don't know how how everybody relates
to that term but
any autonomic nervous system there's a
sympathetic and a parasympathetic axis
of that and and the sympathetic axis is
what's giving us in trouble in our
culture
my results-wise and physiological health
wise
and it's because anything that uses
vocal attention is sort of brings along
with it some level of activation which
is yes
partly you're just looking at a screen
in front of everyone you're right
attention system takes you there to some
extent anyway it really does it totally
does and which brings us to another word
for Paradox which is a catch-22.
for whoever's familiar with movie
versions
or paradox
oh man
if you look at the linear this is
interesting we could we could even say
that
the
the most seemingly
uh distorted part of the perfection
is
the over
vocalization
which is also the most most beautiful
part of of it at the same time
well if you talk about getting that on
the Vista and being oh and wonder it's a
big picture that's sort of the antidote
to it a little bit
yeah
uh really bringing you to your knees
really bringing bringing you to your
knees in awe of the beauty
because it's both the most distorted
like the veil of separation
being
the most the very edge of the attractor
of Maya and it being also the most
beautiful aspect of creation is God
totally forgetting itself in the
solution
it's going to mention it's part of the
idea of paradox is that
as soon as things become
self-referential look like an object
language descendants all you have to do
to create a paradox with language is to
make it self-referential so we've made
the statement the sentences untrue
or the sentence is a lie this statement
is a lie by the time it becomes
self-referential
it's really easy to create a paradox
it's a logical paradox
because if the statement's true as false
and if it's false it's true
problem
it doesn't take much to do as once it
becomes self-referential and and our
Consciousness is
really self-referential
I mean
being aware of
ourselves and what we're experiencing is
a very self-referential process
so it's not shouldn't be too surprising
that it would be
in that space
of
paradox
right I mean and then Paradox doesn't
have to be two choices it can just it
can be
hold
spectrum of choices
which is one thing that got me into this
mess in the first place was trying to
understand black and white thinking
and how that can be versus being able to
see the gray areas in between and being
able to see the gray areas has been able
to handle paradox
basically
right it doesn't have to be black or
white it can be all these other choices
in between
you can even have colors
so
it's what makes
a reality so interesting and
complicated Mass
hopefully fun
it's unbelievably fun
yeah
yeah it's very indescribable
ineffable
paradoxical superpositioned
it's very interesting because even
the superposition
it's almost uh
yeah it's a way to say all of all of it
all of it and none of it
when that's kind of the end of it
and
um
and then it's and then it feels really
good it feels really good it should feel
really good
um
because
um one should feel very final one should
feel very complete one should feel
uh very empty of their own conditioning
and empty of their own sense of self and
empty of their own narrative and their
own story and should feel more and more
like a clear vessel and a Clear Channel
for whatever reflectiveness the
collective is seeking for their own
healing and Awakening and that it's a
whole different
existence that is uh harmonically
chiming
the body yeah
it's a whole different feeling
um
it's a really finding pose never lost
so
there's a paradox and the
interpretations of
non-duality
uh
one being you've been in the now idea
but I would contrast that with a sense
of Detachment like there's
also a mother Observer detached point of
view from the now
it makes
The Good the Bad and the Ugly tolerable
yeah because you're not I mean there's a
space that's created
in non-duality that
is just a little bit
removed from the
intensity of it and
it might take a while to get those
through well anyway there's two aspects
to what gets thrown in there to me is
one
idea and the mystical
experience domain or non-dual domain
right you could say that the it
expresses itself in where
there's an absolute Transcendent
spaciousness at the same time there is
an absolute feeling of totally
everything
and yeah so
but but one aspect of it just gives some
space to come up with new ideas I think
it's a creative
it's it's less tightly bounded
by what's allowed
and so you get yeah all these Divergent
behaviors coming in yes tend to get them
locked up sometimes that's right
and then there's a condition
there's a conditioning that people bring
to those experiences that comes up with
all sorts of different points of view
that are kind of all the same thing but
I think
I mean
like if you look at the history of the
Mormon religion where I grew up there
was a
column of light and God appeared before
Joseph Smith and blessed him to be a
keeper of the priesthood and some things
like that that
conformed with his training up to that
point in time his expectation there's an
expectation component to it I guess
based on our prior conditioning and
my expect well I brought to to
experience was
radical agnosticism probably so that's
still where I'm at pretty much with the
Paradox thing
hasn't really changed
whatever I was conditioned to before is
still my condition
right
I think those
those shifts changed
so there's like the idea of quality that
comes in for me I mean I didn't really
think about it too much
hanging out with Dave Chalmers and
Science Of Consciousness but
I've come to the point where I view
quality as like a natural language
encoded in our genetics
and if you look at what smells good to
me versus what smells good to a fly
obviously they're like oppositely
encoded
fly likes things decomposing smelling
like [ __ ] and I don't and I'm repulsed
by it and somehow
in the genome there's probably encoding
for that somehow
it comes into play and so
it's it's like our body and our genetic
code has this built in language
that tells us how we're supposed to feel
about things and
and that basically all of our conscious
experiences
is just built with quality which is like
how it's pixelated it's kind of my point
of view on this
and that's there might be a possibility
to break that code
probably in the Euler number space if I
it was my intuition about it but
somehow or other we interpret
our body interprets the world for us
builds this reality maintains this
reality
and a hologram that's pixelated with
coal here
right and how's that and so there's
somehow there's a language there
that
I feel like we have some hope of
understanding better
at the very least we could map that
brother
the stuff I come across was pretty broad
brush on mapping with it
there's all sorts of different flavors
of pain for instance more pleasure or
color or
what's the quality of feeling right
about something I mean feeling like you
know the right you're sure of yourself
is going to be
some kind of a quality of mopping
and
I think there's a lot of unexplored
territory in that direction
sometimes I think about how to build
conscious or synthetic Consciousness and
and conscious I mean I kind of see us as
biological meat robots and
we're being programmed by our conscious
experience and
for growing up in this dangerous
environment and we're afraid of
everything or fight or flight most of
the time then that's all being encoded
in their neurology to become
subconscious and
and we're navigating that with
Consciousness and solving the problems
and after it becomes routine then it's
just
encoded in the neurology and reduced the
subconscious processes
doesn't require God if it's computable
it doesn't require Consciousness anymore
Consciousness is where we're navigating
it what's not computable
determined they clearly determined us to
anyway
foreign
quality of relaxation
really
that piece and relaxation space
yeah
really that
sort of like vacuuming away
up South back into the void in the
stores
and then whatever is left
which can be some occasional
Fabrications of of self but then even
that is more slightly subtly
deconditioned and Unwound
and just greater and greater peace
love space
all of that
like the ability to relax and not do
anything
and feel that absolute perfection that
everything is is the most
unrecognizable uh
skill
um
and
um like what is the quality of that what
is
um the internal subjective experience of
it because it really it feels like
divinity it feels like crying because
everything's so perfect and you're not
doing anything so everything is
automatically worthy and love and it's
all this tip of what are those emotions
what are those feelings that are coming
up and
[Music]
um
and then
yeah how would we go about
how would we go about mapping
that
and at the same time then having that
urge of oh my bladder is full now and I
was using the bathroom or now I'm
thirsty and so now I'm gonna go drink
some water I'm hungry so I need some
food and
Etc and how are we architecting out
because this is another core thing about
realization
is that mind creates reality
so whatever is believing
right here I
that is creating reality so if what is
leaving
is oriented around what is existing now
we're basically talking about the past
so only by
talking about
the highest ideal possible just as an
example heaven on Earth or whatever
abundant prosperous civilization you
want for children and grandchildren to
Revel in
for millennia
only by holding that in your heart in
your gut in the deepest parts of you and
being unmovable or unshakable
from that
can that actually manifest it's the only
way it can manifest because otherwise
you the same trigger will come up about
some sort of a political conversation
and before you know it there'll be
arguments and all this type of stuff so
the only role you have is to constantly
be immovable in heaven on Earth and what
does that feel like what does it feel
like to know without a shadow of a doubt
that that is what this
is meant to do here
yeah for me I think it's really
important to be able to be
at peace with where things are now both
within ourselves and within the society
we exist in
and it takes a little bit of Detachment
to do that I think especially with
Society
but I mean
one argument I
play around with is you know there's
lots
the valley where I live has been the
side of multiple utopian experiments
over it's
since
white men drove the Indians out
basically
set up their Utopias here and that
hasn't played out well so far
uh butcher said desire to come up with a
better system
and
and
in the current environment there's a
really strong
what I would call wonderful family
syndrome where everything's got to be
wonderful or it's just not worth it
and
and so your ideal is okay everything's
wonderful nothing ever goes wrong and
then I die is that really a wonderful
life or would it you really want to get
drugged through the muck and
overcome something and do something
meaningful and then does that is what's
wonderful life you know right
a lot of people are aspire to the idea
that life should just be easy and
wonderful utopian ideal everything never
crossword and have cousins who grew up
in an approximation to that and they
have not fared well in life Pastor
immediate
House of origin because they weren't
prepared for the real world very well
and so there's one thing I get into is
just how adaptive filtering Works in our
in our brains and
obvious to me is that our brains are
conditioned by or
a lot of us driven by expectations what
we see is what we're expecting to see
it's an anticipatory biased filter
and if we've grown up in a very safe
environment like with the cats we have
an expectation that that's what we're
going to see
and if we have grown up in a violent
unsafe and housed and that's what we
expect to see and it's almost it's a
self-fulfilling expectation we'll I mean
it's
it's likely
there's almost a mind-blindness to
things that we aren't expecting to see
because I mean there's a story I don't
know if it's true or not of Captain Kirk
sailing into a harbor where the
Aborigines in Australia and
uh they were just out in there in their
fishing boats with this big sailing ship
coming into their Harbor and
they weren't even paying any attention
to it because they didn't have any
context for it and
at some point they saw a man on the deck
and all of a sudden they realized oh
here's a contact that's a person
we got to get out of here this is big
bad thing coming at us
and so
and and I think with what we're doing
with AI these days it's easier to
understand how that works because if
you've got an AI That's programmed with
a certain database then it's going to
find things that fit in that database
and if it's outside that it's not going
to see it then our brains work that way
more than we would like to acknowledge
and it's definitely
trying to choose the most out of a noisy
signal by looking for expert you know
based on its past history anticipating
what it's going to find and then
confirming that when it's with the least
amount of data to confirm it but
it gets us in trouble
some people get in trouble because
they're just expecting worse from
everybody and so they'll interpret a
neutral situation to be a bad situation
and
other people will see the neutral
situation and see it to be good and
they'll get taken to the cleaners by
fraudsters
so
what you said earlier is really powerful
which is that
uh who is to say that
the
experience of
uh
of taking birth into an abundant and
prosperous civilization of only positive
qualia is a better
um
feeling of infinity that a feeling of
infinity that gets extremely contracted
in trauma and then liberates itself from
the illusion or does not and just
continues into a negative qualia
fruits
experience and that's a very powerful
question and it's also part of the
Simplicity of things like the
Prismatic refraction of light
um or the color palette
um that
yeah that
there's no
compartmentalization of the best
and then the guiding of it towards what
is quote Best
um
and yet at the same time
there
uh
there is the recognition that there was
a tremendous uh trauma that this
Collective has been through
and that uh
if one would like to entertain some
story or idea or concept or narrative
about infinity and its exploration it
could very much be that this is one of
the
deepest darkest traumatic
experience as it's gone through with
forgetting itself and then waking back
up to remember itself and to build a
prosperous playground for itself here on
Earth for Millennia to come
and that's some funny ass narrative that
we tell ourselves
um
and uh yeah and it's it's up to whatever
you feel really it's really up to
whatever you feel if you feel like you
want to promulgate continuous
transgenerational traumas uh under the
excitement of of creating more uh
suffering to then create greater
Liberation or not
um go for it if you if you want to end
that if you want to create abundance
where children are born into abundant
water food and energy infrastructures
that enable them to and be taught and
still be taught let's say hypothetically
still be taught about suffering and
still be taught about a sense of self
and still be taught about shame and
about these core rude uh emotion
um that they don't necessarily get as
contractive and experience with
if if that uh if that fancies you then
perhaps that's what fancies you and you
want to uh build something like that
where they can uh play uh more where you
can play more freely continually so it's
all it's all a very interesting
color palette and explosion of whatever
you say goes there's nobody else here
but you whatever you say goes fam
yeah
well I don't think we're in danger of
paradise descending upon us anytime soon
so I don't spend a lot on that one but
there's plenty to work with here
reminding people of that you know you
can got lots yeah would you so just if
you want to complain about well that's
just an opportunity
go for it you know I don't think we're
out of opportunities at any time soon
and one thing I've noticed in my
lifetime is when I was young there was
lots of
just survival from Material needs point
of view played into the equation and
right yeah and there wasn't helicopter
parody and stuff like that going on and
you know in a couple Generations that
whole picture is like kids get
everything handed to them and yet
they're stressed it's like there's
almost this Balancing Act between
material needs versus
mental emotional needs as the material
needs become
just headed to people that it's like it
ramps up the emotional trauma for some
reason there makes people more insecure
makes life less meaningful and I think
that's probably a trauma in itself too
a lot of people are having a crisis of
what makes life worth living
hello
and when you're just fighting to meet
your basic needs you don't have to worry
about that it's like okay
my buddy genos is that the first world
problem versus a third world problem you
know there's some reality to that yes
and so
but there's still problems at every
level it seems like they just they
evolved and to take on new forms
I don't know
I mean from my point of view I see
pretty much a never-ending challenge
just from the environment and dealing
with
planetary issues that we've got to deal
with
it's not that then maybe
ways to move off the planet and do
things off the planet and the challenges
that will provide
and there's always plenty of chaos to be
interjected in the physical system so
there will always be that to deal with
navigate
soon right
I'm not worried about running other
things to deal with yes on the negative
side
and I like how this also circles us too
the more that we can hold the hole at
the same time as enjoy the focal the
non-focal at at the same time as vocal
yeah it really just brings so much more
just
flowfulness and peace love
and greater Clarity in what is actually
going on
and
and then enable us to equip us better to
to
understand what's going on and then and
then help Shepherd whatever we want if
we want more abundance or however we see
things however we want
there's plenty of challenge to be faced
in just shifting to a balancing out
masculine versus feminine in our
environment right
that's many generation project I assume
right this is one of
there's been going on for a lot of
generations up to now and it's still not
dealt with
well they're such a good uh they're such
a good access point it feels like
for the male bodies to
to learn the
feminine
there's there's a really good access
point that it feels like
is in the root
the root chakra if you will
and it's something that I feel like
all be making more content about
and but that
when the male
also learns in the male body also learns
how to let go of the contracted energy
around its own root
it can then learn how to close that Loop
on itself that Taurus Loop when this
opens up it can more easily
close that door try to Loop and then
and then also understand what it's like
to be the receptive which is the
feminine female body if you will and
receive and receive rather than contract
and close but like learn how to receive
um
yeah there's there's that and then it
shows up in such simple ways also just
those that will won't even receive a
struggle to receive even a simple
gift of some sort very simple hey you
want to just uh relax a bit honey while
I go and
make some tea or whatever it is like
just no I'll do it myself
yeah but a lot of people have trouble
with that
trouble with receiving troubles just
receiving yes
learning that is an art
a work in progress lots of things are
working progress
yeah
I mean that's sort of my world view was
God's got to be a work in progress if
you want to objectify God somehow which
is dangerous territory
it's more like
the whole thing's a creative process and
it's all a work in progress
yeah the ultimate painter forever
painting
yeah there's a lot of there's a lot of
great
uh topics that we covered and I really
really really enjoyed
the conversation
really
I love hearing that it looks
and I feel like there's so much to still
uh play on together which is really
exciting again I'm really grateful for
Ori
pointing this out I knew as soon as he
pointed it out that I was excited about
it because it's it's very rare that
that he does and then when he does I
know that it's important and more and
more of the conversations that I have on
the show are of this caliber which is
really exciting and it also leads to
what I feel like is
more and more
um osmosis between
whatever lattices and energies are
happening here and then
that can serve
yeah better and it's just really
exciting Jeff I really appreciate you
and I appreciate the world view that you
that you have and
um and I look forward to potentially
continued conversations
yeah those are two
I think what you're describing there is
some parallel processes we don't have
very good language for it yet
I think you're totally unappreciated and
definitely from the feminine side
yeah they will be yes yes that's so good
so
um Jeff what would be the best place for
people to check out more
of you
um that's a hard question because there
aren't too many but I've done
presentations at different meetings that
I've got a little bit of available
online not a lot I could put more pretty
easily
I've got a
a web address at paradigms of
creativity.com
that there's a little bit up on
like like I have some presentations that
I could put links up if I figure out how
to do it
a little bit Tech challenged on some of
the web stuff but anyway
so we'll have we'll we'll maybe have
some of this in the description for
people to go and check out yeah Luke can
put up some more
stuff or put some legs on yeah and
perhaps that's also something that we
can yeah help is get the content
up and help with that yeah
supposed to be working on the writing
project it isn't very far into it yet I
wanted to do a book project around
are you like a self users guide for
conscious robots
and
maybe at some point they'll get
ambitious on that better than I have so
far
basically wrote a
substrate independent user's manual for
conscious agents
it brings in some of the
essential hardware for survival and a
evolutionary environment survival the
fittest environment
it might be Universal across
either biological or non-biological
ways that that could be implemented
but interesting anyway just a way to
play around with
some of the stuff
something it would be a work in progress
ideally you can put in additional
updates and sections as they become more
well defined
right
okay
some of the stuff we've worked with in
an industrial environment where there's
constant updates being issued
and what's the best
way to address a certain problem
yep right someday right
well it feels like that's coming through
coming through as a mycelial network
that's good that's coming through which
is great
yeah and that will help us heal yeah
so excellent and then also uh thank you
everybody also for tuning in we're very
uh grateful that you joined us
and would love to hear from you in the
comments below also so drop us a comment
with how you felt what uh resonated
what didn't that kind of stuff
why
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
yet like the video If you enjoyed it
also share it with people that you feel
like this would resonate with if you
would like to and you check out all of
Jeff's links
um also check out our links the most
exciting projects are available on the
websites below especially home Dow which
is helping us make the shift into the
higher awareness communities and having
the basic needs needs infrastructures be
met across earth
and
that's it I'm really looking forward to
continued play together Jeff
you too
excellent we've got more we could cover
same yeah yeah let's all end the
recording and then we'll uh we'll stay
in here from uh for a little bit longer
all right bye everyone